allez on va bien maintenant je sais
d'exciser on l'aimé bien jouera tous
bonjour au mercy est censée pourtant
c'est un petit peu émue pour trouver
c'est votre anniversaire
c'est mon anniversaire en parlerait on
en parle avec plaisir et je commande de
retrouver le meilleur public du monde
quand tu vois c'est important fayoter
pour commencer le produit ça vous
importants voilà on vient de passer des
mots avec valérie bénaïm danser que de
la télé et il sert parfois de ma vie que
je quitte une femme pour un homme
benjamin c'est vous mais bravo c'est un
petit peu ému passer d'une spécialiste
des boulettes en ce qu'elles s'alignent
même pourquoi pas parce que non mais
c'est vrai que l spéciale des boulettes
va céder régime ouais j'ai remarqué
qu'il y avait deux choses que vous
perdez très souvent c'est les kilos et
les femmes à la donner
vous rappelle que c'est votre première
écrite pour est aussi peut-être la
dernière
il est temps de commencer la semaine
avec le lundi les médias ont beaucoup
parlé de l'autobiographie d'iris
moutonnière qui s'intitule toujours y
croire
oui parce qu'ils risquent de nous
prouver qu'il faut toujours y croire par
exemple j'ai un jour fatou acceptera de
se marier avec vous jean-michel un jour
vous serez fidèles par exemple daniel un
jour vous allez trouver l'amour
on veut pas toujours quoi en tout non
plus bref
iris est toujours en course pour danse
avec les stars et j'ai remarqué que
cette émission créée plus de couples que
l'amour est dans le pré
souvenez vous heureusement que mamie
zinzin n'est pas là heureusement qu'elle
n'est pas là on peut réaliser ses mises
avec son danseur et où un lyonnais
rappelé ryan bensetti avec denitsa
ikonomova et maintenant iris avec
anthony colette
alors du coup tf1 va être obligé de
changer le nom de cette émission
s'appellera plus dense avec des stars
finances en exclusivité ça va s'appeler
tiennent avec les cela vous avez rêvé
assez mal commencé mais là c'est pas mal
quand je reprends donnant vous allez pas
reprendre avant pour que je vais
l'arrêter maintenant je rentre chez moi
déjà bah oui parce que c'était
franchement le début mais pas de mélange
présent quand on était au lundi on passe
au mardi passe donc aux effectifs
j'espère qu'après cette source gamine de
pêche d'enfer vous êtes en forme et en
pleine forme
mardi on a beaucoup entendu parler de
cette femme regarder est-ce que vous la
connaissez
non lundi c'est pas la petite fille des
amazighs à gagner le jeu
du jeu tout le monde veut prendre sa
place alors emporté sa 195e victoire
mardi c'est le record absolu de tous les
jeux télé français et à d'autres
émissions françaises qui ont aussi
établi des records par exemple haslam
qui a battu le record de personnes de
plus de cent ans dans le public
yann un faux du vrai sur canal+ qui a
battu le record de l'émission cas plus
de personnes à l'image que devant la
télé mais ça passe mais ça me passe et
puis surtout il ya les candidats des
marseillais sur w9
caen battu le record du monde de mst ne
parlait que de donald trump qui a
violemment clash emmanuel macron sur
twitter alors qu'ils avaient passé le
week-end ensemble c'est vachement bien
et je suis tiens qu'est ce que ça
donnerait si certaines de nos plus
grandes stars françaises avaient la
coiffure de donald trump par exemple
omar si oui qu'est ce que j'aime bien
dispo par exemple à ce que le bis c'est
un peu le doze icc et je me suis que ça
donnerait si avec le meilleur animateur
du monde
regardez moi ça c'est magnifique bon
alors que mercredi on passe au nombre
annuel à chaque fois on non c'est comme
ça je le dis à mon patrick sébastien qui
nous a expliqué qu'il ne prenait pas
vraiment sa retraite haut les mains il
animera plus d'émissions pour le moment
alors qu'est ce qu'il va faire mon
patrick maintenant à votre avis la boîte
on sait pas encore trop effectivement
moi j'ai des reconversions à lui
proposer il pourrait par exemple se
lancer en politique d'ailleurs j'ai déjà
son slogan et son affiche
c'est pour garder s'appelle plein les
urnes alors regardez c'est de la petite
affiche qui est là voilà les magnifiques
le aimons patrick pourrait aussi avoir
une belle carrière dans les pompes
funèbres
parce que déjà il ya le mont coco dedans
et ça lui va bien il pourrait faire sur
un lebron mais n'a d'autre aussi de
trucs et à sa fenêtre une pub ginel pour
les cercueils avec ce slogan regardez
qu'est ce qu'on essaierait au fond de
cette boîte et on termine la semaine
avec le hongrois d'habitude le vendredi
vous savez sur tf1 il a je vois us kids
avec ionikos évidemment mais
heureusement pour nico ce soir il n'y a
pas de prime à la démission pourquoi
vous parce que vous ne vous arrêtez pas
très en forme vous rappeler la semaine
dernière vous sauvez qui disait un peu
n'importe quoi rêver un petit peu de mal
avec le nom des stars yaka nakamura
alors forcément je me suis amusé à
imaginer si nikos était vraiment trompé
toute la soirée
regardez ce que ça aurait donné
bonsoir bienvenue la 20e édition des mma
couple est international sont là ce soir
comme dj steak mais aussi slim vastine
ce soir sarid à l'idée
son temps les goûts ce choix il dit de
toulouse amour de la france
un suppôt et au lit
[Applaudissements]
on entre alors dans la main c'est pour
rire si vous voulez comme c'est mon
anniversaire
aussi si vous avez envie je peux
m'installer autour de la table avec
plaisir pour le reste de l'émission
écoutez moi je n'y vois aucun
inconvénient
sauf que vous ne sont pas payés allez à
la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]